une vingtaine de proches attendaient
avec impatience vendredi matin où il ya
deux clubs de québec l'arrivée du
voilier nommé caractère avec à son bord
la famille savare legault a d'abord vu
toutes nos amis nos proches c'est
vraiment les bonnes émotions c'est
agréable aujourd'hui on réalise pas
vraiment l'ampleur de ce qu'on a vécu
durant quatre ans et à bord du navire de
12 mètres et demi que la famille à
dormir manger effet l'école à la maison
et l'a parcouru plus de 50000 km soit
davantage que le tour de la terre on
avance à une moyenne d'environ 9 km
heure alors ça n'en fait des tas de
navigation durant leur périple les
savoirs le gotha marie leur voilier dans
une vingtaine de pays on avait ce projet
de villa de partir en volley pendant
quatre ans puis on est tellement
contents de nos tellement content
tellement fier de ce qu'on a réalisé
si vivre la pandémie en mer a été un
moindre mal il ya parfois eu aussi des
moments plus difficiles en 2020 julie
savoir apprend que son père souffre d'un
grave cancer alors que le voilier se
trouve à des milliers de kilomètres du
pays ont j'ai vécu ça à distance à la
maladie d'un proche qui est décédé
quelques mois plus tard ailleurs j'ai
cru que je revienne au québec avec les
filles heureusement mais je les ai vus
j'ai pu le voir la veille de son décès
et
on est resté quelques mois les filles et
moi au québec pendant que jean louis
était resté en polynésie puis en mai
dernier en pleine nuit à plus de 300
milles nautiques au large entre le
panama et les îles caïmans le voilier a
perdu son mât le trajet du retour s'est
donc fait à l'aide du moteur du bateau
plutôt qu'avec les voiles finalement ça
vient n'était pas ce que les pouilles de
blessés mais c'est un moment qui aurait
pu être très très dangereux mais pour
julie et jean les différentes mais
aventure n'auront pas réussi à ternir la
riche expérience familiale vécu avec
leurs trois filles je pense à voler il
est marqué pour reste de leurs jours de
retour à québec le couple s'est déjà
trouvé un nouvel emploi et leurs enfants
ont bien hâte de retrouver leurs amis et
d'aller à l'école on s'attend à ce que
les montagnes russes d'émotions mais on
le voit de façon positive notre tour on
est des projets on est content de
revenir au québec ont aimé notre vie
c'est avant dans la vie reprend pont de
vaux bien qu'elle ne prévoit pas se
départir de son voilier la famille
savare le goût compte bien profiter de
la vie sur la terre ferme pour quelques
années ici oui jeudi par ce nom radio
canada québec